my name is Jonathan keeps and I am an
experimental philosopher what that means
is that I do things like open a
restaurant for plants I sell real estate
in the extra dimensions of space i
choreograph ballets for honeybees i
build systems by which you can become
married by a law of nature using quantum
mechanics i even attempt to genetically
engineered god all of these are rather
absurd on the surface and may not seem
especially practical in your everyday
life however i think that there are some
basic lessons that can be extracted from
them that at least for me are highly
useful even when i am not pursuing
experimental philosophy even when i am
simply trying to get by in the world
basic ways in which an experimental
philosopher looks at the world that can
be divided perhaps into five lessons i'm
going to go over these with you by way
of example looking at some of the
projects that i have undertaken with the
takeaway that you might be able to apply
these rules either to undertake your own
experiments in philosophy or simply that
you can use these in your creative
problem-solving at work or at home the
lessons can be very briefly summarized
as follows
ask naive questions invert perceptions
combine incompatible ideas remix
metaphors and pursue paradox by no means
are these comprehensive and they're
rather glib yet i think that if you take
these as a point of departure as i
sometimes do you'll find that you get
outside of yourself in terms of your
routine
your education and your common sense and
you start to look at the world in
different ways that may lead you to
ideas that you never knew that you had
and so I would like to invite you to
join me in this workshop in experimental
philosophy here on big pink mentor